well joining me now is Jamie Bartlett an
expert in social media analysis at the
think tank demos and author of the
darknet hello to you Jamie it's been
described by some as this never-ending
game of whack-a-mole the minute you
close one account dozens more spring up
what does try to do about that it's
extremely difficult for Twitter Isis
like many terrorist organizations before
them are actually pretty smart using
technology these remember a young men
young men that have grown up with this
technology and they know that the minute
and account of theirs is shut down or
something censored they can start
another account they can build even an
automated bot it's called to create
dozens of accounts to share messages
very quickly move from platform to
platform so for Twitter you they have a
system whereby the community of users
Flags content that they think is in
breach of their terms and conditions and
then they'll go around and try to check
each one and that's important because
what Twitter would say is that we don't
want to be over censorious we don't want
to shut down journalists reporting on
Isis and the minute you have automated
systems and machines trying to figure
this stuff out it tends to be a little
too censorious how powerful a
recruitment tool is Twitter for Islamic
state though because we've seen that
huge surge in numbers of members since
the video of James Foley for example
well Twitter just in the same way that
it is for businesses companies for
anybody really trying to share a message
Twitter and all the social media
platforms are fantastic at being able to
spread messages to a very large audience
at very low cost this is the reason Isis
uses it now how far that then translates
into people reading a tweet or seeing a
video and deciding to leave and travel
to Syria or Iraq that's far less obvious
and actually it usually takes more than
something as simple as that to convince
somebody to leave their lives and travel
overseas and of course when we're
talking about Twitter we're talking
about content that is on in the main
stream now but there's an awful lot
going on underneath as well yes i mean
twitter is very good for propaganda for
these groups because it does allow them
to reach a large audience but beneath
that there's other times groups like
isis want to be more secretive they want
to communicate very privately and
securely and yet there's a whole sort of
cluster of closed chat rooms password
encrypted protected forums which these
groups also use to share messages to
share information and to communicate
with each other and what Isis has been
so good at is combining both of those
things to be secretive on the one hand
and to be very open on the other